hey guys welcome back to the anime
culture corner
today i put this brand of mine to work
questioning what is aaron's end goal
in the mind of our favorite angsty
teenage titan shifter
unless you're unless you're team armin
or reiner
annie amir bert holt okay okay i guess a
lot of people fall into that category
but today i'm breaking down just what
he's thinking what's going on inside
that head of his
an important notice this is an anime
only video looking at what aaron might
be planning in season 4 and how what
we've seen so far will impact the last
season
but first you see that big red button if
you like anime manga or both and enjoy
discussions on new ones old ones
make sure to hit that button almost 94
of you guys aren't subscribed yet
and has a growing youtube channel i'd
really appreciate the support
and now that that's over let's explore
aaron yeager shall we
now i think the most important in
understanding what aaron's planning is
the very last scene in season 3 part 2.
after the survey corps finally arrived
at the ocean aaron states how he used to
think that freedom existed across the
sea
but in actuality on the other side of
the sea are enemies
both the books in the basement and his
father's memories have influenced
aaron's line of thinking drastically
culminating in this crucial last line in
the entire season
okay kind of extreme isn't it aaron
doesn't think that the islanders are
free
which is fair they're kind of like
prisoners they can't leave the island
and have been
essentially restricted within the walls
for centuries because of the mindless
titans put there by the marlians
but at the same time the king within the
walls threatened the marlins with the
full force of the titans within the
walls if they ever attacked them
so in a way while they're forced to be
prisoners the king of the walls impose
this on them as well as a form of
self-defense
neither side is inherently at fault for
the position that the islanders are
currently in
however now that the survey corps have
overcome the former regime and overcome
the will of the king within the walls
the only person left in the way of
freedom is in fact marley
and so we have to wonder why his goal is
so extreme why he has to kill all the
marlins to obtain freedom
while it's true that it's a surefire way
of guaranteeing the islander's freedom
it's a pretty rash inclusion to arrive
to except
if you really think about what aaron's
gone through it's not
a theme we see a lot in attack on titan
is that history repeats itself
especially with reoccurring violence and
aaron sees this
for years and years aldeans within the
walls were brainwashed to believe that
they were the only humans left alive by
the power of the founding titan
through the royal family's twisted idea
of self-preservation
it was only until grisha ate the
founding titan and until the survey
corps successfully took down the royal
government in season three that this
cycle was broken
the constant loop of passing down the
founding titan from one royal family
member to their offspring and so on so
that history could continue forever
without anyone in the walls knowing the
better
it's something they had to fix for
themselves and if aaron and the rest of
the survey corps weren't there to solve
the issue then it arguably
never would have been fixed
in history there's been a constant back
and forth between who is the offender
and who is the victim
initially it was the aliens who
oppressed marlins and spread the will of
the eldings across the mainland
then once they were beat they switched
roles with marlene's becoming the
oppressors
and the aldians on the mainland have
just sat down and accepted this
reiner berthold annie they're all
willing to become titan shifters used by
the marilyn government just to defend
their eldean families
we see that even eldians have accepted
this violence this oppression for what
it is
no one's willing to fight until we see
grisha until we see the memories that
aaron has gained the elding
revolutionary movement that's fighting
for a new age for aldians
however because of this cycle these
loops that aaron's seen in history
aaron believes that if they let marlene
survive again if they repeat the cycle
of violence there will again come a day
when the cycle repeats and
marlins rise up in revolution and just
as the royal family never changed until
grisha and aaron took matter into their
own hands
he must do the same here he must be the
one to finally end the repetition of
history
and it requires the annihilation of
either the eldings within the walls or
the marlians
and the marlinized aldians like reiner
and bertholds to achieve freedom this is
what aaron believes he must do
and so why isn't peace some kind of
agreement a suitable end
why must this be finished by mass
genocide through his father's memories
aaron knows that there can never be
permanent peace
even after marlian's killed other
revolutionaries grisha never gave up his
hope of restoring elder to power
even after burt holt and reiner spent so
much time with the aldians in the walls
making friends allies
they never forgot their true mission to
obtain the founding titan and they
betrayed them
aaron has seen through his life and his
fathers that alternative motives will
continue to survive
and thus a mutual agreement between
sides isn't sustainable at least in the
long
run and considering the tragedy that
survey corpse went through in season 3
part 2
i don't think that a peaceful end is on
his mind in the first place
if he lets so much as one person one
revolutionary live and think of fighting
back
then everything he's built everything
he's fought for will fall apart again
and so this is why aaron wants to kill
all of his enemies
to commit mass genocide of the people on
the mainland for the sake of the future
of the eldings within the walls
it's inherently pretty selfish i highly
doubt everyone will go along with this
plan
without experiencing the memories aaron
has they probably won't understand
and aaron also holds a unique position
of almost infinite power
if he learns how to use the power of the
founding titan he can control all of the
titans within the walls
and so along with conflicts between
aldians and marlians which we know we'll
definitely see
we might see some internal struggles as
well as we wrap up the series
if you haven't yet make sure to watch my
video talking about everything you need
to know before attack on titan season 4
comes out
considering we've only got a week or so
until it comes make sure to freshen up
before this monumental final season
comes along
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses